all right welcome to new game on five
minutes time again let soba play a
little bit more successful than last
time yeah I guess we get it on a king's
indian oh it's playing with c6 somewhat
somewhat rare line usually or the idea
of Plenty five or in this instance going
d6 after all okay play h3 try to UM play
without short castle here maybe
retaining the option of playing a long
castle I plane g4 to get space on the on
the King side and prevent him from
getting any series play on the kingside
himself okay mmm King age 7 just a way
to move I guess okay it's no it's
completely closed don't mind that so I
can easily keep my king in the center or
go go along here later
some pretty good position for white
black young doesn't have any serious
play cannot really play a five even
after a long preparation you won't
manage I guess and what other ideas to
see how fake it ok go for b5 here 86 be
five but also this doesn't look very
realistic but the other hand white has
got the more space and can easily try to
play a three before later this doesn't
move I hope so this connection here I'll
quickly check if yeah I'm still
connected at least ok now it's coming up
with a move b6 yeah ok
okay one idea here is to play h4 h5 try
to provoke him to play g5 to close up
the kingside completely and get them and
completely dead in this Bishop I think
he's maybe trying to play Bishop f6 g5
which is a good idea really now for this
kind of plan i would have preferred to
to have them knight on f3 really ok
let's go h form I can play g5 on Bishop
ethics
yeah still a very very nice position
they even got some extra time okay I'll
just prevent be five
yeah Black is basically left without an
active plan okay need to prepare long
cancelling maybe
yeah what now aged five one thing I need
to be cautious of let's say I play h5 he
plays g5 and then he yeah in a way
threatens to play a 6 a-5 himself and
completely closed the position so I need
to be careful on that I still have some
opportunities to to open the position up
and not completely shut everything down
okay one idea could be g5 when he when
he answers h5 then sacrifice a piece
there this is some interesting but um
well I don't I didn't don't need to
hurry I guess yeah it still doesn't look
very likely that you can play around b5
them the other idea of course is some
night f5 the peace sacrifice here yeah I
guess I'll do that no need to really
calculate this I think it's some pretty
standard to open up the G file
if he takes now I guess he needs to d6
is hanging age 60 saying I guess it
needs to take ok ok what now I'm not a
piece down which is so good news after
all and that's the left got in the tech
um yeah do a play to play a form h 5 is
got g5 the idea or simple idea would be
maybe queen a three with the idea of
playing f6 maybe
hmm not quite sure maybe maybe I'll need
to play a form shouldn't hurt too much
you can take and maybe take on f5 but
this only opens up for the lines I guess
you to be careful about the time here
yeah okay not much you can do about that
yet we'll get we'll get somewhat messy
here maybe this wasn't maybe a four
wasn't such a great idea after all okay
let's let's open it up time warner shake
the director didn't really expect that
move
now this is just chick meadow checkmate
yeah I guess it wasn't done so clear
around here somehow it wasn't easy to to
break through after all not sure maybe
it should be should be good for white
yeah the computer actually gives me plus
three or something but it's still I
don't know it look so it looks a bit
messy still okay at least a winky okay
that's next game